e
town of Conway pursuant to 439 C to see
if they have a interest and then we're
also going to reach out to the New
Hampshire Housing Finance Authority
according to um RSA
204-b colon 2 uh with that the
department respectfully requests
authorization to sell the subject
Parcels as
outlined above thank you thank you Mr
Smith any questions from Mr Smith from
the committee yes just one question well
the people we purchased it from um uh
dealt asked if they wanted to buy the
parcel
back yes uh that's a great question um
we we will we'll definitely contact the
people that we acquired the property
from to see if they still have an
interest I'm not aware of any active
requests for any of these Parcels at
this point but we will certainly reach
out to them thank you thank you Senator
I didn't realize that was an option so
thank you for that any other further
questions yes St uh what's left up there
we've we've taken a real bath
here scalding
bath what is left and and and why
weren't these properties
maintained I mean they they've all
Fallen apart all these houses are a crap
now you can't get anything for them we
paid dearly for them initially we paid
very dearly and in another life I lived
in
cway and I taught at kenon high school
at cway and the bypass was going to be
the greatest thing since slice
bread has to be one of the the the one
of disasters that we have entered into
how much have we paid back first of all
what's left that's key that's question
number one number two we' fulfilled our
commitment to to the federal government
we' paid the all the money back that we
owe right we we made that last payment
in the in the vicinity how much was that
nature Senator through the chair Senator
delandro thank you for the questions um
you are correct we have paid Federal
Highway back uh I think a tune of 28 to$
29 million um the remaining parcels and
I don't have an accurate number for you
today but there's several left to sell
and Market um and as those are sold back
we will be paying back the department
for for those sales um but yes it has
been a long long time coming to sell
several of these Parcels uh for example
several of them on Thompson Road near
cranmore Mountain had been on hold as we
have worked with the town to um finalize
the build and Survey of the um the
bypass Trail uh from himac Lane up to
cranmore Mountain um those will soon be
coming online in the next year so uh we
fully envisioned lots of demand for
those properties um but you're right the
buildings have definitely had a lot of
uh weather um and they have not been
maintained uh mainly due to funding lack
of funding to maintain them um so we're
hoping to sell those soon um the the
land itself is very valuable up there so
yeah hope that answers your questions
yeah sure
uh yes it it it it does but but again
the
state
uh it's we were in the State of Mind at
one time our mind has Chang what about
the circum ritual is that's that's
another disaster is that W is that W
complete now uh the circumferential
Highway brought through sorry please
Senator delandro through the chair um
yeah the circumferential highway is
still an active project it has not been
uh dissolved yet so we're not able to
take the step yet to uh dispose of those
properties that is something on our
priority list to be able to move forward
and uh officially dissolve that Pro
project so that we can actually um sell
some of those
properties thank you further question
sener that's thank you Mr thank you
thank you um move to approve uh motion
made to approve is there a second second
motion's been made in second for item
number 2403 038 if you're in favor of
that motion signified by saying I I if
you're opposed nay motion carries item
240 39 request authorization sell
1.6 Acre state owned nearby Town side of
Route 140 Belmont Road uh Mr Smith would
you continue thank you chairman yeah the
second uh request is um um a request to
sell
1.6 uh plus or minus of an acre located
on the norly side of New Hampshire Route
140 also known as Belmont Road um it's
southerly of seil Road in the town of
gilmington
um the town of gilmington uh recognizes
this as an independent lot of record
it's tax map
414 lot
9-1 um the sale is going to be direct to
the abutters Brian lamarsh and Mark
Hinkley for
$27,000 with an additional
administrative fee of
$1,100 um the uh abutters have requested
this uh to um have additional screening
to their property and to resolve kind of
uh an unauthorized portion of their
driveway that connects into 140 um this
is kind of a long linear piece of
property um that was uh appraised uh by
a by a department appraiser um the value
was
$27,000 um it has been reviewed by the
department it's been found to be Sur
plus to the Department's needs um one of
the conditions of the sale would be
another survey requirement for the
grantee to complete and um and then to
obtain any other uh local um and state
approvals prior to closing thank you uh
questions Mr
Smith move to approve 039 second motion
made and um has been seconded uh for
item 039 if you're in favor of that
motion signify by saying I I thank you
sir do you also have you don't have the
next one do you administrative Services
I do not okay thank you thank you for
your time
sir we'll move on to uh disposal of real
estate uh item
2437 department administration services
enter into authorization for the use
supremacist agreement County of
Hillsboro
welcome sir please introduce
yourself thank you Mr chairman and the
members of the committee I'm Brian Young
assistant administrator of the bureau
Corp facilities with Department of
administrative Services I'm I'm sorry
sir your last name I didn't catch Brian
Young thank you sir thank you
chairman uh the department wishes to
continue to lease out
9,433 square fet of state owned space in
Hillsboro County Superior Court North
it's located in 300 Chestnut Street in
Manchester uh for the Hillsboro County
Attorney's use uh the agreement is for
four years and it's for a total revenue
questions from the committee move to
approve
037 motion has been made and seconded
for item
037 um if seeing no further discussion
if you're in favor of that motion
signify by saying I I any opposed motion
sir our um last item is uh item 24041
New Hampshire Liquor Commission requests
to sell approximately 88 acres of
surplus property two Parcels of land on
the North and southbound Hampton liquor
properties town of Hampton and with yes
it's 040 not
041 thank you for
that item 040 thank you senator for the
correction it's going to be a tough
just break yeah
okay thank you uh sir please introduce
yourself good morning Mr chairman ladies
and gentlemen members of the committee
my name is Andrew Davis I the chief
administrator of real estate leasing and
development facilities for the New
Hampshire Liquor
Commission uh chairman Malo uh will try
to join us he is in the building with
another meeting going concurrently at
this time but he uh he indicated to me
that if if at any point there are
questions that you have that are
specific to him uh we will come back
when it's your
pleasure okay I'd also like to note uh
through oversight it was pointed out to
me by uh Senator Edgar you are missing
one exhibit in your packet you do not
have one of the um property sites I will
provide that to this committee
immediately you only have you have
duplicates of the Northbound side
um I don't think it's all that um
relevant in the context of what we're
asking for today what we are here today
is asking for your uh approval to uh
sell and dispose of what we've deemed as
Surplus
property what has brought us here uh is
a very long journey of uh of an RFP that
we put out uh for the Redevelopment of
our two state-owned properties in
Hampton on Interstate 95 currently they
uh contain a state liquor store on each
side the overall goal and the reason
that we elected to go with an RFP route
as opposed to just a straight sale or
bid was we intend to stay there we are
going to have an ongoing presence uh it
would be analogous to we're going to be
a joint owner an utter whatever you want
to call it we intend to um sell
everything that has been deemed Surplus
with the exception of the the parcels
where we will build our state-owned
liquor store we will own the land
beneath our liquor stores thus uh you
know no property taxes and in an
agreement on and at the direction uh
with Federal highways as well as the New
Hampshire Department of Transportation
which was also overseen by the
Department of Justice we will retain
ownership in perpetuity of the onramps
and the off ramps uh for the what is the
exclusive uh entrance and exit into
these properties so again uh we are we
are trying to do a Disposal today uh of
the Surplus land we have gone through an
RFP process we have um received uh
proposals from from four very solid um
very experienced uh
parties so I won't I won't read the
letter to you I think it's uh
self-explanatory but uh through through
our engagement with Keller Williams
Coastal realy group we have identified
what we believe to be a Target value of
the land and we are seeking your
approval to uh complete our negotiations
uh to get to the point where we have a
purchase and sale contract which will
also contain a master development
agreement articulating the agreements
between all parties and the figure that
we are seeking is not to be less than 15
million the um the also the Genesis of
this initiative it goes back to
legislation uh which again is in your
packets but the proceeds from the sale
of this Surplus property have already
been earmarked they will be uh used to
Commission
questions yes please we'll start with
Senator Lang so just to understand that
you're going to sell all the land except
for the directly underneath the liquor
store and development of the rest of the
land will be whatever private developer
that buys it and develops it whether
they want to put restaurants or anything
else in there that is correct with the
with the exception we will also retain
ownership of the on-ramps and the
off-ramps and the limited right away
access that the Department of
Transportation already enjoys by way of
uh registry documents that'll stay
intact um basically to to summarize when
we met with Federal Highway because we
met with fed Highway as well as the OT
to make sure there were no Highway funds
involved in the acquisition of any of
these Parcels which they've confirmed uh
that was a requirement of theirs that uh
with with the stipulation let me
indicate that if had we received a
proposal that was not um receptive to to
that agreement then then there would
have to be a whole new layer of
approvals from Federal Highway about the
relocation of the ramps or the
reconfiguration so all proposals we we
received met that requirement H yeah yes
follow up please do we do this with any
of the other liquor stores on 93 we have
an eastbound I mean North and southbound
liquor store um do we do we do the same
thing there do we sell all the property
except for the liquor store do we own
that and lease that to the Proprietors
of the various okay sure I can answer
that I was involved so that's a that was
a little bit of a different Model A
different project and I'll try to very
Briefly summarize it back when it was
decided that the hooks that welcome
areas or rest areas were going to be
redeveloped um it was done through an
RFP process um and the the outcome of
that was liquor The Liquor Commission
had owned all of the land on both sides
of Interstate 93 we entered into an
agreement uh again with the oversight of
the Department of Justice in which we
conveyed everything to the Department of
Transportation with the exception of
where our building sits today the dirt
beneath it so everything else down there
is owned by the New Hampshire Department
of Transportation they are currently
under a a 35-year ground lease that they
entered into with the entity that is the
developer operator down there to this
day so we don't own anything else down
in hookset other than our store and the
land beneath
us get one more yes please so again so
in in hookset the state I'm just going
to use the state as a generic it could
be dot or or uh liquor um own owns all
the land that the the gas stations are
on the restaurants are on as well as the
liquor store different entities May own
pieces of that but it's still the state
of New Hampshire owns that and we do a
ground lease for that versus what we're
proposing here is to private sale the
property except for where the state
liquor store is and have a private sale
owner of that rest area yes that is that
is correct and that is that is one of
the critical reasons why it's not just
the person sale agreement but it's the
master development agreement because
again think of it as neighbors um
there's going to be by virtue of the
cros easements and the and the the
sharing of the ramps and of course
there's going to be ongoing common area
maintenance and the the goal of this is
that at the outcome of this The Liquor
Commission will own its own building we
will maintain our own building exterior
and interior we will uh participate in
the maintenance of the ramps because we
own the ramps and and the rest of it
will be owned by the private entity and
and that's being conveyed by a fee
simple interest one more followup please
and I'm assuming we did a cost analysis
of what we make in revenue for the
purposes of the ground lease like we do
in in Hook set as compared to just an
outright sale and the one-time Revenue
no no we did not we did the reason we
did not was because the decision was
made to to convey the property again fee
simple outright interest and the
successful developer operator they you
know another piece of this is currently
none of those properties are on the
property tax roles everything else will
now return to the town of Hampton's tax
roles
okay Senator pro thank you Senator Lang
sort of asked some of what I was going
to but I guess I'll follow up with one
further are you looking to have both of
these properties purchased by one
developer and they they sort of or are
you looking to perhaps have these
multiple different developers purchase
them I guess I trying to understand the
vision here where we're going sure no
that's a good question thank you for
asking um the so the the initial RFP
which was not I shouldn't say the
initial the ultimate RFP RFP
224-1 it let the door open in other
words we were we wanted to see what the
market came to us prior to that we had
done an RFQ to you know to qualify uh
and I don't want tell me when you had
enough uh be prior to undertaking this
those properties had never been surveyed
uh there were no other uses allowed on
those properties by the town of Hampton
through our efforts uh it was
rezoned what was called the interl
interstate overlay District was created
and it was adopted by the town of
Hampton thus you can now have amenities
like food fueling uh there were certain
uses they disallowed uh they were very
clear about that that came in uh on an
earlier round of rfqs so the the um it's
been an evolving process in which we
said okay you give us your ideas you
know you tell us what uh you know what
you think you could do there what can
you bring us what can you make to do
what can you do to make the Hampton
Welcome Center is a little more
welcoming and and that's and so that's
what came out of the
proposals thank you thank you thank you
um I have a couple questions was was
there uh so this is without a doubt of
of Greater benefit to The Liquor
Commission than it is to the Department
of Transportation I would assume
they uh was there something um I know
this is the direction you went um I'm
sure there was a conversation with
Department of Transportation if that
model and having to do 35e ground leases
uh wasn't appropriate was there any of
that conversation or we've always been
moving with the Liquor Commission to
sell the
property no uh to as a matter of fact we
did offer um not only to do but
specifically we offered to dot the
opportunity to acquire it and pursue the
path that they chose to do and hooks it
uh former the former commissioner uh
declined that offer and and with some
very very valid reasons uh you know not
not the least of which you know funding
and
resources um and and not because of
anything negative about what they
undertook and hooks it I want to be
clear about that it was just this
opportunity came along and no other
state agency really seemed very
interested receptive we've also had uh
preliminary discussions with the town of
Hampton uh depending on whether or not
we obtain your approval here today uh
our real estate broker will be formally
offering it to the town of Hampton when
I was going through my multiple meetings
with the town and the town manager uh
they made it they they kind of
anticipated that they understand that
it'll be offered to them but they will
have to pay whatever is the fair market
value at a minimum and and again
anecdotally um probably shouldn't go
into anecdotes but anecdotally they said
no we we'd rather have the property on
the property tax
rules thank you Mr Davis for clearing
that point that that that takes a lot of
uh cloudy out of my thought process um
the uh the sale will be no less than $15
million if it if it turns out that
development costs are too high or the
economy is not what they want and we
have four I believe said we have four
four people that are interested in this
qualified
biders then if it's any less than $15
million it will come back for approval
am I correct in that or do we lose our
handle on this process maybe I should
ask Mr Shay that question but what's
what's your understanding
Sir Mr
Davis um thank you for asking again I I
am not an expert on the process I have
I've tried tried to become I have been
been in front of this committee before
on some other smaller sales and it was
my understanding that whatever level of
authority you grant to my commission or
my agency um we have some latitude
before we need to come back but we would
we will still need if we do not obtain
at a minimum of the 15 million or if you
indicate there's uh you know a margin in
there um and we still don't meet that
number we need to come back to you okay
thank you Mr Chay is that your
understanding yes um the committee when
you first formed you had adopted some
guidelines in terms of when you do
approve um disposal of property when
they provide a value to you the agency
does that the um actual sale isn't um
less than 10% of that value it could be
much greater and they don't need to come
back but if it's less than the amount
that they've proposed by 10% then they
need to come back and talk to you okay
at least provide an informational item
to to explain why that might be the case
thank you Mr Davis you wouldn't mind
another question so I believe in the
presentation it was talked that we're
successful and this becomes a beautiful
property and the Liquor Commission is uh
receiving $15 million you were going to
use that or the department was going to
use that money to pay down Bond
obligations um you have you have two I I
imagine I think I read we're going to
demolish what we have we're going to put
up two new buildings uh
is will that cost will that new cost be
bonded also or will that cost come from
the $15 million and do you have some
idea what that building cost now is
going to
be there's three questions I apologize
that's that's fine that's fine you there
is no
limit here as long as you'll help me uh
thank you for the three questions so
first of all back to the legislation
that that respond to all of this we
sought and we were granted Capital
Appropriations to construct two new
state-owned liquor stores uh the stores
that that are there now are very old
they're very tired they're they're very
undersized based on what we have been
doing in our agency over the last 12 to
15 years um it is our goal and it was
stated in the RFP that when all is said
and done we will have two new St well we
will have two new stores um that will
mirror to the greatest extent possible
the one that we built on the Portsmouth
traffic circle to give you some um some
context the stores that are over there
now are in the you know 16 to 19,000
Square ft uh they've been added on to
over the years and they're they're not
expandable the store we have at the
pouth traffic circle is just under
23,000 Square ft the biders um all as
part of the process uh were're advised
that that's what we want we've actually
had site visits to the Portsmouth Circle
they brought their teams they looked at
them and the proposals that I have
received reflect
that and and and again we we will be
paying for the construction out of our
appropriation we the proceeds of the
sale are already spoken
for okay and do you have a an idea of
the cost to build your two new
structures based on um modeling of what
was done in the pouth market that store
cost somewhere in the vicinity of 7.2
million
okay thank
you the um my my last U go right ahead
I'll come back to M's a wrap up please
go ahead sender so so I guess that
bodess the question so you're going to
build the new stores whether we approve
this sale or not is is the two are not
connected
correct I would have to defer to the
chairman of the commission but it is my
belief that is our intent we still we
still need two new stores yeah all right
thank
and um a followup the four groups U the
rfps have put put out there and I
believe there are different
philosophies from the four Builders what
they would like to build and the size of
of what they are intending to build if
I'm
correct um and I I just want to offer
this as food for thought to take back to
the
commissioner a business that I've owned
for 30 plus years is a convenience store
in gas
operation and my store operates 24 hours
on Route 16 and I'm not a Gateway I'm
one of 20 within 20 miles of me and my
operation is 6,000 square
feet I I would hope that when you get
down to the point of choosing something
and knowing what we see in
hookit I I don't believe one or two of
these proposals is large enough to even
handle what we're looking for that's
just me as a Layman as a businessman and
I would I would just like you to take
consideration thank you sir so not
chairman thank you yep the um is any
further
discussion is there a motion for item
040 actually Mr chairman thank you I'd
like to just say a few words first and
then make a motion uh please go ahead
sir um this has been quite a undertaking
and it's involved the town of Hampton
quite a bit and there's been a lot of
talk in town about this over the years
and we had to overcome a lot of a lot of
obstacles uh to get to this point so uh
I just I wish a luck on this this
endeavor and it should be good for the
town and good for the state and I'd like
to uh make a motion to approve uh number
40 second there motions been made made
and seconded uh any further discussion
seeing none if you're in favor of the
motion uh item number four zero uh New
Hampshire Liquor Commission please
signify by saying I I any oppose motion
carries thank you
sir thank you chairman and thank the
committee again very much all right
there's an
informational uh item here is that Mr
Right miss Shay um item 041 Hampshire
Council resource and development that's
correct all right does does anyone in
the committee wish to have further
item then sh all the members were um
emailed A draft copy of the banal report
um so the banal report is basically all
the activity that this committee has
approved since you started um and what
we try to do at the this time of year is
get an update on the value of the
properties may have been disposed of so
if they came in and asked for
$100,000 did they get 100,000 they get
125,000 so we tried to provide an update
for that the report's due by December
1st so that's why we try to get it to
this last meeting so unless anybody had
any comments or changes um we'll just
update the draft report with the
activity from today um we'll get the
chair to sign some letters for us before
you leave today and then before December
1st we'll have it submitted to the
proper places any any questions on that
one Yul done thank
you U with that motion to adjourn second
motion been made second to adjourn if
you're in favor of that motion signify
by saying I I those oppose nay we have
concluded our